yeah it does feel like office hours
that's what i yeah that's one thing i
enjoy about watching you know watching
your podcast
it's great fun and it's it's informative
for that reason you go into some depth
and
makes it really interesting i just feel
like i'm taking an
it's exam little stressful
i just finished up an interview with
kevin knuth kevin knuth is a physicist
at the university of albany someone who
i reached out to because
he's one of the rare individuals
interested in the phenomenon
of ufos aliens uaps whatever you would
like to call them
and he's a respectable physicist more
than respectable in fact
i didn't realize how excellent
creative originative he is until
i started researching about him after i
had already booked the interview
and then i found out that not only is he
interested in aliens which is
it's not a goal of this channel at all
i'm more interested in the physics of
aliens and
what they have to say about
consciousness as well as our role in the
universe
not only is he interested in that but
he's done
significant research into the
fundamental laws of physics with him and
his colleagues conceiving of
a theory called influence theory we'll
get into that the conversation is pretty
much two parts
aliens and then fundamental physics i
didn't expect to get along with kevin
anywhere near as much as i did
he probably to me was
one of the guests i felt the most
relaxed with for whatever reason
maybe our personalities drive at some
unconscious level i don't know what it
is but hopefully you enjoy listening to
the conversation
as much as i had having it please if
you're interested in seeing or listening
to more conversations
like this then consider donating at
patreon.com
literally every one of those donations
helps
not only financially but motivationally
thank you and enjoy i watched several
interviews
over the last few months since we first
um connected when was it early i guess
late fall or something
so i've watched several interviews
they're always they're really engaging
and interesting and and i
and i feel jealous you get to talk to
all these interesting people
two hours of just one-on-one which is
quite nice right that's hard to hard to
get
which one did you like the most if you
don't mind me asking
yeah um no that's a good question um
i'm pleased i don't mean to put you on
the spot if you're actually if you're
being
overly polite and saying that you watch
that i don't know what no i'm trying to
i'm trying to i enjoyed eric weinstein's
that was
he was a lot of fun to watch um
he was quite dynamic i've been super
excited to talk to you when i first
contacted you it was because
you had a paper still do paper out on
uaps i believe they're called which is
the ufos essentially for those who are
listening
analyzing them and you're a physics
professor so you're not some
let's say loon from the periphery
and i thought okay that's interesting
because very few academics actually
pursue this
and i assume you're tenured so very few
tenured people let alone non-tenured
pursue this and then i realized you had
some papers
but this is a channel on theories of
everything which means we explore the
foundations of mathematics the
foundations of physics you have many
paper you've been thinking about this
for quite some time so you turned out to
be far more interesting than
i had initially thought and that's not a
slight that's actually a huge compliment
because
i see that you're able to derive spin
and probability and space time
when i say probability i mean the way
that it's used in quantum mechanics and
momentum
from relatively simple ingredients i was
just reading about that recently
that is fun we're going to talk about
that later if you don't mind
no that sounds that's great one of my
favorite topics so
thank you for coming on well thank you
for having me i i'm
really looking forward to this for those
listening or watching there's going to
be an exordium on aliens first
if you're mainly interested in the
foundations of physics
then look at the timestamps and view or
listen to accordingly
we're going to talk about aliens
why don't you tell us about the benthum
encounter from 1951
uh right so that that encounter
happened um in 1951.
um graham bethune was um
he was a navy pilot they were
summoned to
iceland to reykjavik to
because the the in
iceland they were having problems with a
ufo
operating in the area and um i think it
was operating in a
maybe near an airport or somewhere
sensitive i don't recall exactly what
the difficulty was
and they were summoned there to
basically check this out and help them
out with this
problem um they got there no
no didn't see anything the thing with us
the thing was gone by that time
and they were heading back across the
atlantic from iceland
um toward newfoundland and
while they were flying they had
they saw lights on the surface of the
water
on the ocean below and it looked like
city lights and at first they thought
they were
they were out of um off course
and so they double checked their course
and realized no they're on course and
they thought well there must be ships
maybe naval ships operating in the area
or something and
and um and as they got closer the
um these lights were basically was a
disc shaped light
um a ring i guess and it appeared to be
under the water
and as they approach this thing this
thing shot up from the sea surface to
their altitude
in a very short period of time like a
matter of a second or two
and the
and this it was basically a large
um large disc i think he described it as
being
uh 300 feet across i probably
i needed i actually printed out my
paper here too and when you felt some of
these details
there's a lot of cases and um yeah so it
was several hundred feet across
um the disc was slightly below their
altitude so they could actually see this
disc it had
like glowing around the periphery and as
the object moved um the
the color of the light would change so
um
and i think it's been described as
looking like a plasma
so this object basically was with them
for several for several minutes they
basically steered
um the one of the one one person wanted
to steer toward it so they steered
toward it
and um and eventually the thing took off
but it was seen by pretty much everybody
on on board um
i think there were like on the order of
20 people or so on board
who witnessed this thing so this thing
then took off and they estimated its
speed
as it left to be about 1500 miles an
hour
which is about what was picked up on
radar they were close enough to
newfoundland that
they were able to detect this on radar
and they confirmed that later
when they say that it changed colors of
the lights as it moved
yeah is that akin to the doppler effect
or is that something different
it's something different i think because
it was it would go from like a violet
a red violet to a yellow and basically
within those ranges
and and i don't remember which way it
went
when it was when it was moving it was
yellow and it was stationary it was red
i think that's basically how it was
that that detail i might not recall
properly
what do you attribute as the cause of
that or the reason for that
i don't know i i mean it's hard to
figure out
you know i try to treat these
observations as evidence right we're
basically
trying to do some kind of physics
detective work to try to figure out
what is this thing how is it operating
how does it fly you know these are all
the questions how does it move so fast
these are the questions that come to me
as a physicist and
um a lot of times these the light
emitted by these things
appears to be a plasma so um
it could be that you're basically the
object is ionizing the air around the
craft
and that's what emitting the light and
then as the
object moves you basically maybe it's
changing the electric fields
around the object and and then changing
the
um the excitation and the gas
okay professor how did you get
interested
in this subject you're not a fool you're
not just
some loon you're not some what someone
would think of as the stereotypical
person who studies
alien encounters or professes that
aliens exist or ufos or whatever it may
be
how did you get into what what started
you off on this journey
i'm a physicist so i'm curious um
and i'm often surprised at how uncurious
some of my colleagues are
but the yeah so i'm curious about these
things and i've always been curious
and when i went to graduate school
it would have been the fall of 1988
it was probably about our second first
or second week in graduate school so it
was in september of 88
there was a cattle mutilation
i was at bozeman montana and
the there was a cattle mutilation and
i'd never heard of
anything like a cattle mutilation i grew
up in wisconsin and we have cows in
wisconsin and i've
heard of cow tipping but who's going to
mutilate a cow that's horrible
so i had i was
pretty shocked by this and
there were a lot of people um
concerned about this on the news they
didn't know whether it was
alien or if um if there were satanists
involved and there were lots of theories
floating around so we were discussing
this in the
um we were discussing this in the
hallway then
the new graduate students the ones who
basically moved moved to montana
and had never heard of this before were
discussing this and um
and it was a very heated discussion very
passionate and
everybody is upset and worried and
wondering what the heck is going on
what kind of crazy place did we just
move to um and are going to have to
spend four or five years here
so um so this was really our concern
and while we were talking one of the
professors came out of his office
and um came down the hall to see what
was
you know we were so excited about and we
told him what we were discussing and he
said yeah that's
that's interesting he said it's this
happens here
we don't really know they never figure
out
how the cows were mutilated and why and
there's very often ufos seen in the area
around the time so it's so it's
interesting but it's never figured out
and
we just move on and
you know we i don't i don't think that
helped calm us at all
and he then said but what's very strange
what's even more
interesting he said i have a number of
friends in the air force
up at malmstrom air force base and they
have
trouble with ufos flying over the
missile sites
shutting down our ice cbms
and this was in 1988 this is 1988 i was
told this
by a professor at montana state
university
and now now i've never heard this before
in fact i didn't hear about this
publicly until i think around 2010 when
robert hastings had a press conference
um with people from the air force from
malmstrom air force base
and so to be honest we when the
professor walked away we
we laughed about it i mean you know
there's ufos shutting down nuclear
missiles
and he was a professor of what what was
his
physics he was a physics professor what
particular field of physics
i don't remember who it was because it
was my first week there and i didn't
know all the professors
i have i have a guess who it could be
but i don't but i
don't want to say because yes i don't
know for sure
yeah have you ever tried to reach out to
that person afterward um
no i haven't um it's unfortunately i'm
at that age where
a lot of my professors are have passed
away so
so i didn't try reaching out i probably
that probably would be a good idea
though
okay continue that's a good suggestion
thank you
um yeah so
we um so we laughed about it and then
it was kind of a running gag through the
whole semester
you know and then oh and you know there
are ufos shutting down our nuclear
missiles
and you know we would always giggle
about that
but it really just seemed unthinkable
because
our our militaries are restricted
these are restricted areas if we have
somebody coming in shutting down our
nuclear missiles
our military if a foreign nation did
this
we would go to war over it and probably
nuclear war because the nuclear missiles
are involved
and so so it's unthinkable that we
wouldn't do anything and so it was
really hard to believe
and it just
you know i just remember the event it
was just something somebody said once
and
and went on and it wasn't until um
maybe 2015 or so that i was preparing
for
an astronomy class and i had we were
going to talk about astrobiology and i
had some students asking me about
the possibilities of aliens visiting
earth
and and wanted me to talk about that
so i was online looking for
papers anything that i could you know
could use to put out
together a reasonable lecture on the
topic
and i stumbled on the um robert hastings
press conference and
where he had i think six people
um all working and at nuclear missile
sites
i think three of them were from
malmstrom air force base and
and i started watching this and i was
just watching with disbelief
thinking oh my god i heard about this in
1988
and the professor who told me then said
it was going on then it was
in the present happening in 1988 and
these people
in the press conference um robert salas
salus was one of the
prominent people um he was talking about
an event in 1966
and i thought well wait a minute you
can't have
a crazy story like this if somebody's
making this up in 1966 it's not going to
persist until 1988 these are
professionals
and they're serious professionals they
have to have you know clearance and
specialized training and
and and these are secure areas they
they're not they're not nut cases and
they're not going to joke about things
like this
and certainly not for 20 years and
and i thought there has to be something
to this something must be going on and
and i thought this really has to be real
i can't
see any other way around it um
and i can imagine and at that point i
could imagine that
we don't do anything because the
assumption is that
it can't be real so let's not do
anything and
and and i think that's why
there's been a lot of inaction and lack
of interest
i'm gonna share my screen and then
you're gonna if you don't mind please
tell me
what is going on here
okay with this all right
so basically what i'm basically doing
here
is if you
let's see so they were estimating
they they so grandpa then this is
said that it cooks yeah this is from
1951 this is right now
from japan or nimitz right
so so here the penalty i work from
penalty because
so they were they estimated the
um the distance to be about five to
seven miles away
so he wasn't exactly sure how far away
it was
and so what i bet did basically is i
i used a um
basically he's estimating this looking
out from the plane he's looking down at
an
angle in front of the plane and so i i
treated that angle to have some
uncertainty so he's going to be off by
i think i say what it is in the in the
paper he's off you know potentially off
by so many degrees
so so what i did is i did a monty
monte carlo sampling where i basically
randomly sampled
um angles with a gaussian distribution
about the angle that
you know he would have been looking or
thought that he was looking
and um and that gives you a distribution
of distances
so i'm basically doing a monte carlo
sampling
to um take into account potential errors
my question the question i've always
asked
when you know when pilots are confronted
with these stories is mike
the question that comes to my mind is
how how wrong could they be
um these are trained individuals um
millions of dollars go into their
training
which doesn't mean they're perfect um
but but then
then that begs the question how
imperfect are they how
how wrong could they be about you know
some of these facts
and and i can imagine
you know when so for instance if they
estimate the size of the object as being
300 feet across or something um
how wrong could you be with that well
maybe it was 100 feet across but it
certainly wouldn't have been 30.
i mean nobody's gonna mistake a 30-foot
disc for a 300-foot disc
well you wouldn't even be able to see
that if you're five miles away
approximately so he's five miles away
and he's looking down and he's looking
down
five miles away huh and he was able to
see that it looked like city lights
yeah it looks like it was a circle
circular group of lights
okay now let's look at this then you
estimated the
altitude and also by the way just as a
technical design why are
you using monte carlo it seems like just
help edify me here seems like you have a
gaussian distribution or some sort of
distribution
why not just use that distribution why
do you have to then sample it so that
it's spiky at the edges
oh i i use i could have used that
distribution the problem is that you'd
then have to
in estimating um
you know estimating the speed of the
object i then
have to basically use
the uncertainties in each of those
quantities that go into calculating the
speed of that object
and so it requires transforming you know
all these probability distributions
which
is quite tedious okay and so doing it
with monte carlo
doing monte carlo i'm going to get
appropriate answers and it's a faster
way to do it
otherwise i might have to take
approximations and things like this to
pull it off analytically which
i didn't want to have to do i see the
computer can't do that
it's not as simple as putting it into
wolfram wolfram alpha
or mathematica no not always because
you've got to i mean you're
you're um you're taking derivatives and
inverses and things like this you've got
so okay and if you see me looking off
over here
it's that i also have some of the
studies on this side as well so please
okay i'm not you're the only thing i'm
paying attention to no that's fine
then you've got times going on here you
have altitude you have minimum log 10
okay well that's the acceleration that's
the acceleration altitude
okay altitude and times and these are
referring to the altitude is referring
to what
the altitude is referring to the
basically the altitude of the craft so
how how far it went up from
the sea surface great and then the time
is referring to how long did it take
from that altitude
yep okay okay simple simple simple great
now let's let's get to japan
airlines flight 1628 in 1986
right that was that's another instance
where
i knew about that incident in 1986 i
remember watching it on
nbc news with tom brokaw and i remember
him discussing this and then playing
some of the
um some of the audio from the pilot
and the air air traffic control
and i remember thinking that this is
really pretty amazing you've got
a you've got a um
you've got a large jet
it was a 747 i guess it was um
and it's basically flying from they were
flying from
paris to tokyo bringing beaujolais
nouveau
so here now we can all have a giggle
hahaha has got a plane full of
uh wine right um but
so supposed to aliens were after all
that's right and you were an undergrad
at this point i was an undergrad at the
point
studying math and physics math and
physics yeah okay great great
yeah so so the um
and you can actually still find the news
reports online
the videos people put them online but
the um
so as they're flying they're approaching
anchorage alaska
and um they see some lights in the
distance basically approaching the plane
and so
they're concerned so they call um air
traffic to control to see if they have
any traffic for them
and air traffic controls is negative um
they said
well we see traffic there we've got
um several craft approaching and so
they're
very concerned about this so approaching
anchorage they have
um two craft approaching and then
um and then shortly thereafter a larger
craft
approaches and the thing is walnut
shaped and glowing
and at one point it's it's in front of
the aircraft
and the pilot described it as so big
that they couldn't see out of the
windscreen
so i mean you're you're a pilot of a jet
you've got something in front of you
that you can't see beyond
that's a scary prospect um
so he's panicked and and calling air
traffic control and they don't
they're not picking anything up on radar
except his plane
um and at some point the military
is contacted and gets involved and on
military height finding radar they pick
up
um the larger craft on the plane and the
airplane so they pick up both objects
so the so the military is able to detect
this with their radar
um were you able to estimate the size of
the craft
um no uh he estimated it to be
um the size of i think it was three
747s so it's basically the size of an
aircraft carrier
so you've got this guy you've got a
flying aircraft carrier shaped like a
walnut
um now you then you have to ask
how wrong can the pilot be i mean it's
all right maybe it wasn't as big as an
aircraft carrier maybe it was just the
size of a destroyer
still that's pretty amazing right he
said it was glowing
i mean glowing yeah and this was at
night
um i i don't know what time it happened
i don't recall
that's all that's all recorded but i
don't recall off the top
is that it with the japan airlines
flight is there more no well the thing
the the interesting thing is the object
follows him for 40 minutes
so it isn't just like i saw it it was
gone no this thing basically kept track
kept along with the airplane for 40
minutes and it basically moved around
the aircraft
and moved around the airplane um as time
went by so
it would go so the military height
finding radar in this radar data
exists you can look at this the
military framing radar is sweeping every
10 seconds
and the craft is about seven and a half
miles away from the airplane
and in one sweep it'll be at one o'clock
in the next sweep 10 seconds later the
thing could be at six o'clock
and so the thing is literally jumping
around this airplane and the
pilots panicked he actually takes some
evasive maneuvers at some point
to try to evade the object and thought
that he had he didn't see it
and the um air force comes on and does
now it's behind you
it's still following you it's behind you
so
the thing basically followed him for 40
minutes
and and then he went down and landed
when you said that the pilot said that
he couldn't see
beyond the ship if it's five miles away
and it's the size of a
carrier why can't you see beyond it you
can see the edges of it no oh well this
one
was moving around so so at some point at
one point it was very close he had said
and i was initially he couldn't see
initially he couldn't see beyond it
so initially how close do you estimate
it was to him
i have no idea um let's say it was
the size of a carrier then it would have
to be
i'm sure this is a simple trick okay
yeah yeah you could figure out how close
it would have to be
for much of the event it was about seven
and a half miles away according to the
radar
and the sweeping i'm sorry it wasn't 10
seconds it was 12 seconds so it was
every 12 seconds
great okay this data exists meaning that
it's public
yeah the radar the radar data yeah
how does that go online does someone
leak it or does someone release it
right it was um john callahan
who was faa chief of accidents and
investigations at the time
they basically re-enacted the situation
in one of their one of their
testing centers and they the
and that's where the data comes in so
they can reenact it
and then they re he recorded that and
basically saved that himself he saved a
copy for himself
and he claims that at one point the
president
reagan's scientific advisory team
um met with him along with cai
cia officials and fbi and a number of
people
and they confiscated all of the data he
had um although he didn't tell them
about everything he had some of it
stashed away
but they met with him and they were very
excited because they said that this was
the longest
encounter that they had had any
data for okay
let's get to the nimitz encounter i'm
sure many people are familiar because
that's
david fravor if i'm correct okay
and that's in 2004 i believe right
okay why don't you give a brief rundown
for the people who are unacquainted with
this
all right so in 2004 you had
the the nimitz um carrier group was
was off the coast of san diego
california about about 100 miles 150
miles off the coast
and um senior chief kevin day
was operating radar
for much of this time and for
overall for a period of of a couple of
weeks
he was picking up um anomalous
um radar targets appearing basically
just appearing on his radar
at about 80 000 feet which is really
very
of very high altitude um which at
airplanes passenger jets fly around 35
000 feet so these radar targets are
appearing at about 80 000 feet
and they typically were appearing south
of catalina island or near san clemente
island
and then they would track south at about
120 knots
um down to guadelupe island
in mexico where they would then drop off
as radar
and so we nobody knows what happened to
them after that
um so having an aircraft um flying at 80
000 feet
at only 100 knots is almost impossible
there's not much air up there so you
you need to go much faster to have lift
so that's already anomalous
so this anomalous in the other direction
they're moving too slowly
right so
and kevin day had observed these and
um you know they weren't
in the operating they weren't where they
were operating so
this wasn't really a big concern at this
point
um and at one point
he um he he well he said that there were
times when they would drop from
they well they came in at 80 000 feet
when they appeared they would they would
drop down to 28 000 feet and that's when
they would track south
at at 100 knots so so even at 28 000
feet you aren't going to be flying at a
plane at 100 knots
but from 28 000 feet they would
periodically drop down to the sea
surface and that
amount of time to go from from basically
at a constant altitude 28 000 feet to
sea surface which is zero um they would
do that in about point
seven eight seconds so it was less than
a second to go from
basically rest in the y direction at
twenty eight thousand feet to rest in
the
y direction at zero feet okay now to
interject
how long would that take if it was free
falling
um i'd have to do the calculation but
it would be let's say estimate it to a
significant digit it's fine
you can be off by a factor of 10. right
so the time is going to be
um basically twice the height
twice the height divided by the
acceleration acceleration is about 10
10 meters per second squared 28 000 feet
2 times 8 000 is 16 000
and now i'm going to divide that by 10
meters per second squared
and i'll get so that's
16 000 divided by ten which is sixteen
hundred
and then we take the square root of that
so that's going to be uh forty forty
seconds
forty seconds okay so i
they did it in one second so that means
yeah less than less than one second yeah
okay and and they came out
and they came to us let's say our
fastest
accelerating technology downward
whatever that is whatever kind of crap
that is
how fast approximately do you think we
could do it
right if you could dive at 10
g um acceleration and then slow down
for the other 10 g then um
you're basically going you're
accelerating halfway so we can find the
time to the halfway point
um but if you work this out it's it's
one
quarter um it'll be one quarter a t
squared so so the total time is going to
be
basically so we've got 32 000
divided by 100 so it's 320
seconds squared so then now we have to
take the
um basically the square root of 320.
so it's that's less than 400
the square root of 400 is 20 so it's
going to be a little less than 20
seconds
okay let's take a look at some more
i'm going to share my screen with you
and just so what are we looking at over
here
this is the nimitz video then we got
different models and we have what is log
z
what is log l what is a what is and so
on all right
yeah so what we're doing is we're
testing different um
dynamics uh kinematic models these are
these are
basically in in this section of the
paper we're analyzing the
the video that was released by the us
navy
and the last the last few seconds of
that video
32 frames or something the
object is locked on
begins at the the targeting system is
locked onto the object and it loses lock
and the object takes off to the left
now it's not a very impressive departure
um and none of these videos are nearly
as interesting as what the pilots
describe
these things as doing um so i'm
convinced we were given
probably the most boring videos they
could find
um and very possibly videos they didn't
expect
any thing anomalous to to come from so
that acceleration doesn't look very
dramatic but um
so we so we basically tested several
models one of one of the models is that
it accelerated
um just accelerated off the screen so
it's constant acceleration
another one was accelerated for a
shorter period of time
and then um just coasted off the screen
at constant velocity
and um and so those are the basic models
we we were testing
and so why do you think it is that they
didn't you believe that they have more
interesting footage and they chose to
release this
they it being the us government yeah i'm
just guessing that
based on what the pilots have you know
what numerous pilots have said
in these types of encounters um
these things behave much more amazingly
than
than the footage they you know they
released so
david fravor when he encountered the the
tic tac object and it finally took off
he said it
accelerated like it was shot from a gun
and it was gone
in you know out of sight in two seconds
so um clearly this acceleration isn't
that fast
so it's so so that's why you think it is
that they released
the video if you were to speculate at
all the us government
um that i don't that i don't know i know
that um
lou elizondo and chris mellon were
working on the inside
to try to get some of this information
out
because they weren't able to freely
discuss this
um you know amongst the intelligence
community
so and so there's probably multiple
concerns there i mean one is that if
you're
if you're not able to you know you've
the navy is having problems with these
things
right but they're not able to discuss
you know these objects and have it taken
seriously so now
now what do you do um in 2015 for
example
the they were having near day nearly
daily encounters with ufos
um and so you've got pilots who are not
trained for these types of encounters
some of these were happening in the
persian gulf area while they were
operating you know so that's a you've
got a military campaign going on these
guys are going on bombing runs on
in syria and they've got to fly through
ufos
be over the persian gulf and then go to
syria and then conduct their military
operations and come back and
that's a huge hazard i mean you don't
you don't need a pilot
shaken you know from a ufo encounter and
then go into a war
zone that's extremely dangerous and so
there's one reason why when people say
oh they're just drones and the us
is just testing them now you're going to
test them by putting
pilots in danger in a war zone um
that's not going to happen what are some
other arguments against them being
drones
i mean first their their accelerations
that we estimated are
are way off the charts you um people
can't handle much more than you know
than
10 10 to 15 um g's for
any period of time 13 g's
um the new f-35 fighter
i think is rated for 13 and a half g's
and at 13 and a half g's its wings will
rip off
so you can't accelerate an airplane more
than about 13
15 g um
some missile frames can handle handle
higher accelerations
they can maneuver up to about 30 g's of
acceleration
and some can withstand structurally
withstand
up to about 60 g's
so most of our equipment can't handle
our equipment can't handle more than 100
g's
and um and that's in one direction let
alone stopping and then turning around
yeah well i mean it doesn't matter
whether you stop and turn around because
you've got so many g's here and then so
many g's again
so they're doing it over and over again
it's it's insane
what are these associated with these
crafts
well the the highest one we estimated
was about five thousand
seven hundred g's um that was the one
picked up on radar by
um senior chief kevin day while he was
on the uss princeton
with the nimitz carrier group that's the
one that drops from 28 000 feet to
sea level in 0.78 seconds
so you're looking at over 5 000 g's of
acceleration
in that case the other situations were a
bit lower
i think the lowest ones we had were
maybe i think the um
the video from the 2004 nimitz video
when it
when the object when the targeting
computer loses track and the thing takes
off to the left
you're looking at about 78 g's
the object's moving to the left and away
from the
from the airplane at that point
see what strikes me about this paper is
going through it
if the mathematics isn't beyond high
school
or beyond first year that's for sure and
i'm wondering why is it
why hasn't an analysis like this which
seems like
anyone could have done it why hasn't it
been done before
this is simply the stigma against
analyzing i think that's the problem
i mean you've got you've got numerous
capable
physicists who have commented on these
things
and you've got enough information to
basically to do a back of the envelope
estimation of the acceleration
and they're more willing to say well
it's probably an atmospheric effect
who knows who knows what it could be
that's usually the response you get from
a professional physicist which is
problematic this is a calculation they
ought to be able to do
who else in the physics community
professional physics community is
studying this besides you and your
co-author ah well let's see my
um a colleague of mine matthew chidagas
at um university albany is also studying
this
um other physicists
i know of a few
um people let's see
i don't know if they're all physicists
um some are engineers
do you know of any physicists who are
interested but tell you this behind
closed doors
yeah that's basically the the situation
you've got a
number of people who are interested in
studying this
and the problem is there's a paucity of
data we don't we don't have
any real data to work with um for the
most part
you have you know witness testimony and
some of that paper is based on witness
testimony and we did the best we could
with it
um and and i think it gives you a
ballpark estimate of what was observed
but but you have to you really want
um you really want radar data you really
want to be able to triangulate positions
with multiple cameras you want to do all
sorts of things like this
that would be ideal
are these spacecraft getting faster with
time what i mean by that
is let's say someone was analyzing
earth's craft
i imagine that what they would see is
our top speed would increase over the
decades because it has however with
these crafts
do you see them as being predominantly
the same since the 60s or since the
50s since you guys had since that's a
good question i mean i don't
think that we have that information um
you'd have to look over look at them for
a very long period of time
and there have been sightings of
objects like this and if they are alien
spacecraft which we really haven't
proven that that's the case yet
um the you know if they are alien
spacecraft then we wouldn't know
you know from some of the roman reports
of flying shields
uh we aren't able to estimate speeds and
accelerations in those cases we don't
have that
detailed information so what's the
romans report of flying shields
oh there's several there's several
reports in roman history of
um or orbus claipayus i think they're
called
um but they're called they're flying
shields basically
and so i can send you references for
this there's a
um there's a couple of papers um
one on ufos and classical antiquity
and um and another paper on the same
topic
yes do you mind making a note to send
that to me later yeah
certainly you're only sending me about
romans or are you sending me
is there a list of ufo sightings or
potential ufo sightings across history
there's a book um
by jacques fellais um i keep hearing
about this
called wonders called wonders in the sky
and he has a compilation of
of curious accounts basically that could
be interpreted as
you know maybe the same type of
phenomena
is he still alive yeah yeah he lives in
the bay area
okay i know that this is
as a physicist you want to stay within
what you know
but if you don't mind speculating why do
you think they're shutting down
our nuclear devices do you think that
that's just a side effect it's
inadvertent like maybe when they
accelerate that happens for whatever
reason
or do you think it's purposeful why do
they selectively shut it down in this
area and only at certain times
that's a good question i don't know how
i don't know the manner in which they
were shut down
i mean this stuff is still i mean i
don't think i don't think
the military has admitted that that's
actually happened
you have people who worked at these
sites who
claim that it happened um the most
detail i've heard was from robert
salas and he said that i believe it was
him and he said that it was a
failure of the um
[Music]
basically a failure of the of the
navigation and guidance systems
and that then led to a shutdown
so that's curious because now if you
have the inertial
nav you know inertial navigation systems
failing
you know could that be due to how the
craft operates
so maybe it's just a side side effect
i mean i i mean at this point you know
this is extremely hypothetical so i am
just
making up stories here but i mean if you
have a craft that basically is somehow
warping space time or affecting space
time and you've got an inertial
navigation system sitting nearby that
could
affect it so and then if their systems
are set up so that they shut down
whenever one of these things goes
haywire then the ufo flying over it
could
be enough to trigger that to shut down
is it on purpose is it an accident i
don't
i mean these these things have to be
studied and we have just gotten to the
point where
people are admitting that they're real i
mean after
after 80 years i think that's a little
to me i find that a little scary
and we've had this this going on for
about 80 years and it took us 80 years
to decide that it's
they're real um but we still don't know
what they are
you know what they're doing here 80
years you're referring to the 50s
from the 40s yeah late 40s there aren't
any reports
from the u.s government of ufos prior to
the 40s
i don't know about from the u.s
government there are reports of the ufos
prior to that um easily into the 1800s
numerous ones yeah
by ship captains and things like this
these things have been seen for a long
time which is another argument against
them being
american or russian chinese drones
they've been observed well before people
could fly so
there's someone who came out recently i
believe they're israeli
talking about ufos i don't know i forgot
the person's name i don't know the story
do you mind edifying me as well as the
audience
oh yeah well that was an interesting
story i don't remember his position and
i don't remember his name but he was
in the high up in the israeli military
and he claimed
yeah is he the one israeli director of
the space program it said
right so is he the one that claimed that
they were in contact with with
alien alien civilization here
for avi loeb from earlier today that
talks about this so the question was
okay i would like to hear avi loeb's
opinion on the claims of former israeli
director
of the space program hayim ashad brought
forward he must have heard about this so
and so they went through the news
briefly
um was it a hoax i guess this person
isn't
recapitulating what hen or hem a shed
said
because he's assuming obviously about it
some government officials
you know have had some pretty um pretty
exciting or interesting claims and it's
you know these still aren't
substantiated so
it's it's difficult it's difficult to
know how much of it is a claim how much
of it is a mistake
how much of it is
a problem with the individual you
you know we still have all of those
questions
when i spoke to jeremy corbell he seemed
to think that the aliens were
shutting down the nuclear arms as a flex
of their sovereignty
and well what you're saying is it might
be inadvertent
i'm also wondering why is it that people
can come out
like david fravor and so on other people
like you mentioned
from the government and not be sued by
the government or
shushed by the government or simply
destroyed
killed how are they allowed to speak
about it
i know you don't particularly like bob
lazar or believe bob lazar but let's
imagine
bob lazar is correct let's just imagine
how is he allowed
there are people like him maybe not to
the same degree
right i don't that's a good question i
don't know um
i don't know much about workings in the
intelligence community so i'm not sure
how they would operate they may have
um opted to eliminated individuals in
the past
um i think at this point it would be
rather you know it would be fishy and
would probably draw more attention
than anything
so i don't know if i don't know and
you know if they you know if you have a
lawsuit where you sue them for talking
about this well then
now you've basically admitted that it's
true or some aspect of it's true
and so that would be a problem too
something else that's puzzled me about
aliens at all is that
our rate if i'm just going by our rate
of
technological improvement is drastic
every decade and
for sure every century so some people
would critique every decade like peter
thiel but at least
every century that's for sure and when
you take a look at
let's imagine these aliens are going
back to their planet that takes a couple
years
it from some other time frame it'll take
it may take them a
depending on their accelerations it
could be a few days to a few months
um for for us it can take it for us it
could take a thousand years or a hundred
couple hundred years so
yeah so let's just imagine they're going
back to their little alien civilization
in some other planet okay then i would
imagine that that planet
has increased its age by maybe a few
decades
then i would imagine that when they come
back they should be far
more technologically advanced each so
every decade for us when they're going
and coming back presuming they're going
and coming back
i don't see why it should look the same
at all because i would imagine that if
it was us
we would look vastly different every
century or so especially
century from now maybe our planes look
like triangles maybe a century
from maybe 200 years from now our planes
would look like dust
and then maybe farther it'll look like a
planet and so on you understand the idea
yeah so why do you think it is that
there's somewhat of a constancy
of the reports in terms of how they look
of visual inspection maybe even their
speed
of aliens given that we are so
quick with our technological advancement
and they're presumably far more advanced
than us which means their
trajectory of let's say moore's law or
whatever it is that they follow
should be they should be farther along
in the exponential curve
no that's an excellent that's an
excellent question and i
have a hypothesis that could answer that
in it
and i came up with this in response to
the
general reaction of so so
so it's we we we know well that if you
can
get a craft up to um relativistic speeds
if you could engineer something like
this so yes
huge engineering fee whatever we don't
even know how you'd pull it off whatever
yeah but if you could then time dilation
works
in your favor it works in the favor of
the traveler right
so so you could you could conceivably
leave your homeworld let's say you come
from a thousand light years away
you leave your home world and you travel
to earth and you
can travel close to the speed of light
so you can get here in a few weeks so
it's a few week trip to earth
that's nice for you um it will be
it'll take about a thousand years if if
that planet's a thousand light years
away from earth
it'll take a thousand years in the
galaxy frame so a thousand years will
pass on earth and a thousand years will
pass at home
and then now they hang out here they go
into
you know they land in a meadow and can
and
chose that on purpose um and take some
biological samples and then they take
off and head home
now on the way home it's another
thousand light years
so for us in the galaxy's frame it's
going to take another thousand years for
them to
get home um maybe a couple weeks for
them
again so for them what it was a you know
a few month trip
um has turned into a 2000 year trip back
at home
and the argument you know while while
relativity would work in favor of the
traveler the question is who would do
that
because what society would ever conceive
of a mission that would take 2
000 years because the people who
designed the mission are never going to
see the results of it
and the travelers are going to come back
to a culture that's totally different
than the culture they left because of
the the the um reasons that you're
stating
so so why would anyone do this well the
the supposition is that they are
going to go home um and that they live
on a planet and i think that's
you know that that's what we have
implicitly assumed there
what we've neglected to remember is that
even on earth
there exists nomadic tribes and there
still exists nomadic tribes
so you could pull this off if you were
a nomadic society not a planet-bound
society
so imagine you know you and me we want
to go space traveling but we don't want
to
be ten you know a thousand years apart
um i'll head off to
um to the star rigel or something 900
light years away you pick another
place to go about about as distant
and we plan to meet back up here at
you know a certain time in the future so
we can plan our trip accordingly so that
we come back here at the same time
and it may be 2 000 years in earth's
future but
you know we don't care we can still meet
up and compare notes and then we can
travel off again
so you can imagine that you could have a
whole breakaway civilization like this
where it literally is a civil
civilization of travelers
and that's what they do they travel and
they travel and they explore
and they periodically meet up they have
meet up points
and meet up times that are all
pre-arranged or they have some algorithm
for this
and um they can then exchange goods they
can exchange
information and travel again and what
they're basically doing is they're using
relativity in their favor
using time dilation in their favor and
they're basically
but but they're not just space traveling
they're also time traveling into the
future right
so they're they're traveling through
space interstellar space but they're
also traveling through time
by racing forward into the future with
respect to the rest of the galaxy
so all of them and their friends are
also traveling around
to meet up at the same 2000 year future
relative to the galaxy yeah they might
not they might not have a single meet-up
place they might have multiple meet-up
places
and just randomly meet up but yeah you
could do it various ways
and if that was the situation then you
could take advantage of relativity to
travel
you know galactic distances
and um and
the advantages i mean it would be very
interesting because
you could um so imagine that you
accelerate you know at a thousand if you
could accelerate at a thousand g
like you know similar to some of these
objects we've observed
you could accelerate at 1000g halfway
decelerated 1000g
the other half you can get from one side
of the galaxy to the other in just a
couple
weeks a couple months um so
so let's say it takes you three months
to get from one side of the galaxy to
the other and then you can come back
and when you come back it's taking you a
six month trip
but you know in the galaxy's frame it's
going to be about a hundred thousand
years later
so you get to travel through time and
and so now your perspective of the
universe is very different
um first when you first
when people look at you they're going to
see the same ships
you're traveling in the same craft and
why do these craft not evolve
because it's actually the same one it
could actually be the same craft
so the same craft that was observed in
roman times could literally be the same
object with the same you know beings in
it
you know two thousand years later they
could literally be the same options
fascinating fascinating fascinating so
let's imagine this is a 10-day journey
for them
and for them it's just time for them
it's a couple days yeah so
they would be you so they might be very
now for them
we are ephemeral right and
um because they're when they come back
you and i are going to be gone so
there's no point in making friends
there's no point in landing on the white
house lawn and introducing yourself to
the president
because the next time they come back the
united states isn't even going to be
here
it'll be something else another culture
so there's no point in getting to know
the locals
so it could explain why they you know
and if they study
you could then actually study a
civilization so their
concept of a civilization and how you
study civilizations would be very
different you can actually watch
civilizations evolve right right
we're kind of like fruit flies to them
right now so they could
oh that's right that's it's fascinating
fascinating
so it would be like imagine for the
people listening
to get some to get another analogy for
me as well is
i'm pressing play on a movie and then
i'm speeding up the movie you know you
can do that on google you can speed up
by
2x but imagine you speed up by 300 x or
a thousand or whatever maybe a million x
and then every once in a while you come
into the room you're like oh that's an
interesting part of the movie then you
walk out of the room then you come back
okay so for you it's just a couple days
and you have a few of your friends who
are doing something similar
so from the movies perspective if they
were to look out they would see
oh there's someone who has similar
characteristics as the person before
fascinating fascinating why do you think
it is that aliens look
somewhat like us at least
when at least from the reports
and again right right and again we're
taking some of these reports to be
serious because just like we're taking
some of the reports of the crap to be
serious
it seems like it's not that wild they're
not octopus
they're people with two eyes four limbs
so that's a good question um i don't
have a good answer for that i would
imagine that a pasta if if that's really
the case then i imagine
that the it could very well be as
a situation of convergent evolution
right um
and we we don't really understand yet
how
you know different environmental factors
affect evolution but you know we can
look at earth's history and get some
ideas so
uh fish shapes right fish shapes the
fish shape works great in water right
nice and streamlined if you're shaped
like a fish
and there have been other things with
fish shapes right the same shapes you've
had
um you have fish that are fish shaped
you have
reptiles that are fish shaped the
ichthyosaurs right and you have
um mammals that are fish shaped whales
and dolphins
so that same shape evolved multiple
times
because it's an efficient shape
so having two free hands
is very useful to building spaceships so
maybe if you look like an optic octopus
and you're very
brilliant you don't you know or if
you're a dolphin
dolphins don't have thumbs go back to an
onion article
you said dolphins don't have thumbs so
they're not going to build spaceships it
doesn't matter how smart they are
that's not going to happen and so it
really could be something like that
another just to go off on a speculative
jump i've heard this
said by some of the people who have
encountered aliens or supposedly
encounter aliens
that we're an experiment so one is that
okay this is just what happens with
convergent evolution
but another is that they somehow caused
us
and then that's why there's a
correlation and that one is fascinating
because i remember hearing someone say
it might have been lazar it might have
been someone else say that i don't think
it was lazar
someone say that the aliens referred to
us you know
this is obviously presuming that we can
speak to them or that they it's all true
the aliens refer to us as carriers or of
vessels of something
of what that's scary let's just imagine
it's true of what
of consciousness of a soul of
biological material of what
yeah some of these yeah some of these
stories are very strange
and it's really hard to
know what to make of them um it's it's
far easier to just say
it's got to be nonsense right and we've
but we've been down that road
several times now well you you just gave
me such an you just
i don't know was this something you've
been working on for a little while that
little theory where they come in and out
and
yeah for for about a year yeah about no
i came up with it about
two years ago and i presented that idea
at the one of the conferences with the
society for
um scientific coalition for uap
studies so i presented it to them i have
a
video of that talk that i can give you
the link to
please write that down if you don't mind
because even if i don't
watch it which i hopefully do i
hopefully get the time to watch it i'll
still include it in the description
so other people can watch it sure
yeah i've i've started writing that up
as a paper but i haven't finished that
yet
right there are two facts about aliens
that always
troubled me about them so one is that
they look too much like us there's two
human in other words but we just
found a way to get around that one
convergent or two they caused us in some
way
and then number two is that the rate of
technological progress should be
should be so far so quick that
they would be unrecognizable there would
be no
through line to even call them aliens
across the decades especially across the
centuries
but you've managed to find a way around
that as well that's fascinating
that's fascinating so now what i'm
wondering i'm sorry to get off on this
idea shooting back and forth no these
are fun things to think about
great great great now what i'm wondering
is imagine if
i have a let's just say fish tank for
lack of a better word
and that fish tank i can turn up
the rate at which time passes on it so
again this is like that movie analogy
it's going at a trillion times our speed
okay so i'm turning it up what i want to
do is i want to
test out imagine i'm just testing out
how is life going to work in this
scenario
so i can start it maybe it's even
there's a word for this panspermia
yeah right okay so i test out what it's
going to look like then i come back and
i look
what is i wonder if that's what's going
on wonder if we are just some experiment
for them the whole alien abduction
phenomenon is very strange
there's a lot of strange aspects to it
and one thing that
bothers me is that the if the
number of people who claim to be
abducted are if that's actually correct
if they actually
have been then then the question is why
and what are they doing to them because
you don't need to you don't need to
abduct a million people to do a
scientific experiment on
on the human body right um you
only need maybe a thousand or so so
way too many people are getting abducted
so the question is what is actually
happening
would be the next question i'd have if
the if the abductions are real of course
right right have you found any credible
evidence to the alien abductions and
have you found any
material that's foreign embedded within
some people i know that some people
claim
no i know that there are is
a group at least one group that is
studying alien abductions in a more
detailed way but that's all that i know
about
all right okay let's talk about bob
lazar
why are you suspicious of bob lazar not
that i'm not suspicious or suspicious
i'm just curious because someone who
studies aliens
to me they they just want they just
accept what bob says especially because
it validates what they've been thinking
right i'm suspicious because
he has supposedly as a background in
physics he claims to have
have a master's degree in physics and
when he
describes
he he's careful about describing
the physics with
enough detail to be tantalizing but not
enough detail for you to be able to tell
whether it's correct or not
can that not simply be a function of
ignorance so for example
he just doesn't know beyond that point
because it's not clear how the craft
work
that could be that could be part of it
he just might not know
um
yeah no i mean that could be part of it
i just i just get the impression that
that he is walking that he's i get the
impression he's purposefully walking
that line between
you know of giving enough information to
be tantalizing and sound
sounding um you know realistic
without giving you enough information to
be able to test it
have you watched any of his technical
talks i only know of one maybe there are
more
i don't know if i sent it to you there
is one
80s i don't know i would like to see it
i guess i'd like to watch it
i should have sent that to you because
he talks about how he thinks the craft
work and there are
diagrams and then he also refers to
element 115 i'm sure you've heard that
over and over
right which is interesting because he
associates the strong force
as gravity number two or gravity number
one which is
to me one of the reasons i got
interested in this kevin
is because i'm interested in the
fundamental laws
of the universe and so how do you unify
qft with gr
okay now if you're claiming that the
strong force has something to do with
gravity
that to me is extremely interesting
right
yeah have you heard him talk about the
strong force
in that manner and then what's wrong
well i've heard that he said that but
that's all that i
i know about it i would yeah so i'd like
to watch that talk
actually that would be fun me and you
have to have another conversation after
you watch all right
if you don't mind that'll be no i would
love to
okay you said i've been in contact with
eric bart who is currently
a pi at skinwalker ranch pi meaning
private investigator
uh no principal investigator like he's
the principal scientist
he is working for um
brandon fugle who owns the ranch and
um and they're performing their own
studies so
so i don't really get a lot of
information from him about
you know events or details so um
but we have talked about you know
possibly
you know sharing information at some
point he's contacting you because you're
one of the few that are actually taking
this seriously or you contacted him
i contacted him initially because i was
i was working and i'm still working on
trying to get
satellite imagery of ufos or uaps
and since they had had sightings on the
ranch
um and they know the place and the time
they might those would be good
candidates to get
um archived satellite imagery
so you could get get a third-party
confirmation that you know from space
that yeah
there's a there's a disc there hovering
over the ground
why can't you do that with any of the
other reports
you you can obviously some of them are
older but what about yeah well you
should you should be able to
and i've been working in that direction
so
the difficulties i've had mainly have to
do with
um my contacts at the satellite
companies you know they're usually doing
this as a favor
um pulling images and and once
you know we get to the point where they
realize that i'm looking for ufo images
then i think it's
like well you know their opinion becomes
more like well i have real work to do
so well that's gonna have to sit up go
to the back burner
it's unfortunate because i think it's a
you know potentially you have
a big discovery and this third-party
data would be
really useful and um
so i i am still hopeful that we can do
something like this
there are satellites orbiting the earth
that are taking pictures of virtually
every part of the earth and their third
party
that doesn't violate any laws by the
government no
i know i i don't know what the laws are
but um but i know that they
that there are several companies that
have global coverage
um and very
you know relatively short time intervals
so
that's interesting i didn't know about
that as for spacecraft so this is
we're nearing the end of our spacecraft
question then we'll get to the physics
okay
great so as for the ufo spacecraft do
you imagine that they're
taking advantage of some new physics and
when i say new physics what i mean is
physics that we don't understand so
maybe like lazar is correct with the
strong force being a gravitational one
or maybe there's a fifth force
or maybe they're utilizing your
partially ordered set manner of
constructing space time from the ground
up
or do you think it's just technological
sophistication in the same way that a
cell phone if
the cell phone isn't using any new
physics quote unquote
since the 1950s we pretty much could
understand how this operated
it's just the technical sophistication
do you imagine it's technical
sophistication
or the utilization of new physics it's a
good question
i suspect that there is some new physics
and the reason i think that is because
we don't see
these things appear to be violating
conservation of momentum
so when the object takes off you know at
this huge acceleration
there's going to be something moving the
other way right um
and that we don't observe that so you
have that problem
the fact that they move through air
almost effortlessly with no sonic booms
um is a problem
the uh yeah so for instance that the tic
tac object that was
observed on radar to drop from 28 000
feet to sea level
in 0.78 seconds at the midpoint it had
to be going about 35 000 miles an hour
that's mach 60 right that's great
and that and that's as fast as the new
horizons probe
that went to pluto so that little
that little tic tac object basically as
it dropped to sea level
accelerated to the speed of the new
horizons probe
within 0.4 seconds
which is really remarkable
um and so it did that without a sonic
boom
and um and it's not clear how that's
possible so
it really does look like there's some
new physics involved
um and then for people who then question
the you know there's the question always
often comes up why do you assume that
these are x
these are spacecraft and the answer is
really simple
because they travel at the speeds of
spacecraft
that's they travel at those speeds
and they travel with accelerations that
could
would not only make them viable
interstellar craft but it would make
them
excellent interstellar craft so
do you believe that they have some base
on earth that's actually where i thought
you were going with your
little theory before when we were
talking about
why the traveling and the yeah yeah yeah
i thought that you were going to say
that
well perhaps they're not going home
perhaps they're not leaving earth i
thought you were going there but do you
believe that they have some space
sorry some base on earth maybe under the
water maybe on the other side of the
moon or something i think there's been
there's been a lot of suspicion that you
know a lot of talk that there could be
underwater bases
um you know 75 percent of the earth
surfaces water
and we really have very little access to
it
so if you are going to hide out
somewhere that's perfect
um and then to be honest if you're
if you're aquatic in the first place
let's say that you come from an aquatic
environment
aquatic environments on planets are
going to be much better
to live in than atmospheric environments
atmospheres have a low heat capacity so
the temperature varies a lot
throughout the day even right you get
huge temperature variations
um and then going from planet to planet
you have huge temperature variations in
the atmosphere
you know go to mars and you're looking
at 100 degrees below zero fahrenheit you
go
to venus and you're looking at 800
degrees fahrenheit
it's dramatic and the air pressure is
dramatically different
you know from planet to planet so here
we have one atmosphere of air pressure
you go to mars it's 1 100th
and you go to venus it's a hundred times
you know so you've got four
orders of magnitude of variation of air
pressure
and and um
and then of course air doesn't do much
for protecting you from cosmic rays
and meteorites right so there's all
sorts of problems with living
on a surface protected only by an
atmosphere
but if you live in an ocean you know
going to another planet with an ocean is
actually
a pretty good thing if you if you know
it's a water ocean
then a water ocean on another planet is
going to be between the temperatures of
you know 32 degrees fahrenheit and you
know 212 degrees fahrenheit
so so the temperatures aren't going to
change dramatically from
ocean to ocean going from one planet to
another
and you can and because water's not
compressible the the pressures aren't
going to change that dramatically either
um the pressures are going to be a
function of gravity but
you know a very deep ocean on europa
either pressure
you know the pressure halfway down maybe
30 miles down into
europa's ocean is going to be similar to
the pressure at the bottom of our oceans
only five miles down
so so you can actually find a nice
place to hang out if that's your
pressure you're used to
you know the only different the main
differences are going to be
um the chemicals dissolved in the ocean
so are there some chemicals that are
poisonous to you in that ocean
or biologics you know if there's you
know
bacteria and things like this that could
be problematic too
but otherwise going from one ocean to
another is almost
going to be going pro for the most part
you know for survival purposes will be
very similar
do you think that if we were to pass
over an alien civilization
presuming they're underwater and we were
able to
see them that they would sense us and
then relocate quickly or they would just
allow us to observe them
just speculating oh i don't know that's
a good question
um yeah it's hard to speculate what
somebody else would do
i'm not even sure what humans would do
in that case so
right do you think that they're building
a base or do you think that they're
somewhat
they're somehow living in their craft
underground because there's not much
room in those crafts and at least i
don't imagine there to be
i don't know 300 foot disc would be
pretty good it depends how many
how many people you have in there
hmm that's fascinating this whole topic
there's so many other questions i had
for you but
i just feel like exploring this and
exploring this and just so you know i'm
not someone who's into conspiracy
theories
or strange phenomenon i'm much like
yourself i'm pretty sure that's just
like you
but this is absolutely fascinating and
it's it's even frightening
because what the heck are we like and
now i'm wondering
how much of this is actually just an
experiment by them
because well that to me makes the most
sense as to why they
i don't think convergent evolution would
produce intelligent creatures that look
like us each time i don't think so
it could be the case but i don't buy it
only because we have one data point
and maybe aliens are two data points
strange yeah well the problem is that
the thing the thing that i wonder about
is if they're
if they're dna based right if they have
the same kind of biochemistry that we do
then then it's hard to
imagine that we're not related in some
way right
so are they from
you know so then you start wondering
about all the possible are they from
here
which would be very surprising um
are they from here did we really miss
something big um
did they come from here originally and
go somewhere else and are coming back
did they are they from another
another system where there was some kind
of panspermia between you know that led
to
you know biology spreading from one
system to another so that we're of the
same
you know so that we're somehow
biologically related to one another
otherwise i'd imagine you would be very
much
you know the situation you would expect
would be
very much more like what um
stuart kaufman from the santa fe
institute would have described where you
have
the biology is probably very different
and you
run the risk of you know you don't want
to touch them because you're going to
you know your biology isn't compatible
so there's going to be all sorts of
horrible chemical reactions
um so we don't want to touch them
yeah well you don't want to come in
contact with their organic molecules
because
you don't know what kind of reactions
you'd have
so you because well so so in stuart
kaufman's talked about
auto catalytic sets where you get sets
of
organic molecules that auto catalyze
right
and so our biology is basically one
whole system of
of these types of chemicals so we're all
compatible with each other but
if you get another organic molecule and
that's foreign
you know that's going to interact with
different ways and create all sorts of
new types of molecules so
i haven't heard of that before yes that
is stewart kaufman
stuart kaufman yeah model catalytic sets
or auto catalytic
molecules or what auto catalytic sets i
think it was and he
i think it was his book at home in the
universe i believe it is
but you know the implications from that
is if there were
aliens who were truly alien the eu
and they were but they were you know
made of you know they're carbon-based
then the chance that the molecules are
similar as
you know are is going to be it's going
to be problematic
why do you think they mutilate cattle
that's a good question i don't know i i
don't know hundreds i don't know if they
do
i mean we the real i mean the real
answer to a lot of these is
we don't know anything yet about these
things so and we don't know if these
things are all related okay sorry
what could be a reason they mutilate
cattle let's say like that yeah
are they doing experiments are they you
know are they collecting data i don't
that's a good question i don't know
well cattle are the most plentiful of
all the animals
actually by weight at least
yeah i had a i had a thought
i had a an idea and i would share the
idea with you so this is
you know not even at the level of a
hypothesis right or this is just a
thought
so
ray stanford who has
studied ufos in the 70s it refers to
a sense of he calls it euphoria spelt
ufo
ria euphoria okay and he
says that when you are near one of these
craft you have a
feeling of euphoria and
he's recorded electromagnetic
variations in the electromagnetic field
from these things
and those variations happen around 12
hertz so
that's interesting because 12 hertz is
close to the alpha rhythm frequencies
that you get in the visual cortex when
you close your eyes
okay wait sorry i just want to make sure
i'm understanding this so who's this
person who's saying this
ray stanford okay so ray stanford is
saying
that there's a phenomenon called
euphoria
yeah okay and he's defining this
phenomenon right now he's not referring
to something else
yeah the phenomenon is the feeling that
you get the sense of euphoria actually
um it's about things so it's related to
euphoria it's related to happening yes
because i know that some people feel
abject terror
yeah so certainly yeah but but but
he says that when the craft are just
near even if you're not aware of them
you'll get that sense of euphoria and
he's
he claims to use this to go you know
he'll have that feeling and then
go outside and oh yeah there it is
there's one um
and takes photos and so he's done that
in the past and that's what he claims
so i so i was curious about this because
he had
also measured uh variations in the
electric field that
are around on the order of 12 hertz
which is close to our
alpha variations where where they're
reported
yeah so when you when he's taking photos
of a ufo
he'll have he has equipment that
measures you know
em em fields so he'll measure the
electric magnetic field
and you get variations oscillations
about 12 hertz
are prominent sometimes so
the so that kind of caught my attention
because and this is where the thought
comes in right this is his claim
you know i have not seen this myself
i've not measured it and so i
i can't you know testify to the
to how true it is but my thought
what struck me was that 12 hertz is
close to your alpha rhythm
and and um
and so if you have strong electric and
magnetic oscillating electric and
magnetic fields near these things you're
going to induce currents into the brain
and if these currents are at 12 hertz
they couldn't train the algorithm you
can actually entrain of the
alpha rhythms so um so you could enter
and train an alpha rhythm which would
which could very well make you feel
you know calm or restful or sleepy or
you know euphoric or something like that
now of course
this could be overridden by the terror
of seeing you know
you know this craft and you know aliens
coming out of it or whatever
might happen but but it that was my that
was my thought well maybe maybe that's
where the euphoria comes from it's comes
from these oscillations in the electric
field
and then it made me think that um
and i had this thought watching the
video
from skinwalker wrench of the disc in
the sky with the cow
dying right the cow was dying while the
disc was hovering over it
um where was this from this was uh taken
at skinwalker ranch and it was in
their there's their tv series their
documentary series
right what's the host name dude travis
travis taylor travis taylor yeah
is that the series you're referring to
yeah it's the one yeah i would like to
talk to travis have you ever spoken to
him
yeah i have i've met him he's an
interesting guy yeah yeah so so in that
in that case you had you had the you had
the the disc is hovering or
some distance above the cow the cow
actually died there
and and it was acting funny beforehand
and it made me think well
the cows brains are different sizes and
i don't know what
frequency their alpha rhythm is at so i
thought
what if what if these craft are inducing
currents into the cow's brain and then
it
makes them panic or something instead of
giving them the sense of euphoria
ah that's fascinating and so
maybe these maybe so what if what if
they're killing the cows by
accident so here's just a thought
they're killing the cows by accident
right and then they're trying to figure
out why the cows are dying whenever
they fly near them right so then they go
down and they did take some samples and
collect some data to figure out why the
cows are dying
um maybe that it's a thought that's all
yeah it's a fun thought it's fun to
think of things
so yeah yes yes there does seem to be an
association with radiation especially
magnetic
sorry electromagnetic radiation and
these craft from that tv series
i recall them saying that all of the cow
that's kyle's a skinner walker were
placed into one
room the size of this condo and it was
magnetized
do you remember that that all the cows
were placed in there i've heard that
yeah
yeah there was some bizarre
yeah there was well there's several
bizarre stories
having to do with the cattle now what
the heck can explain
that i don't i don't know what can
explain half of what i've heard happen
locker ranch so that's how
that is okay let's talk about skinwalker
first that's a whole other kettle of
fish
let's open this cattle fish with
skinwalker
there seems to be reports of ghosts
bigfoot and so
every phenomenon that's pretty much
everything you've ever heard of
it happens there which is very very
bizarre
what's the relationship what could be
how about that what could be the
relationship between ufos and the rest
of
other paranormal activity like
why so here's one here's one simple
answer that when the aliens are nearby
in the same way that they induce a a
different conscious state
then in the same way that low frequency
sounds i'm sure you've heard that heard
of this low frequency sounds can
produce reports of ghost sightings maybe
there's something similar happening
but then that wouldn't explain any
actual footage
like or inter-subjective agreement
as to oh i saw an animal that looked
like this over there
i would imagine that it would just
produce strange phenomena and each
person would have a difference yeah
inter-subjective agreement is a good
term i've often heard
yeah i wouldn't explain that you know
i've heard
professionals claim oh it's a mass
hallucination
and then i have to remind them you know
that's not a thing either right
that's not a real phenomenon either so
yeah
yeah i don't i don't know what can
explain this
let's get to some physics man i want to
stay on this topic so bad
but let's get to some physics sure
we'll transition by talking about
consciousness usually i say that for the
end
but do you have any ideas as to how
consciousness arises is it emergent
and is there a connection between aliens
and consciousness
i would have no idea what that
connection is some people
seem to make a connection but i don't
have an idea i don't have any ideas of
where that connection is
i i have very boring thoughts
about consciousness compared to other
people i think
i don't i don't think of it as being as
dramatic
as many seem to think the
i mean and maybe we're
thinking about different things so
when i think of being conscious you know
i'm conscious of my surroundings
i'm conscious of my state um
and that
that to me doesn't seem to be
much of a miracle i'm not sure what
what's so difficult about that
um and so it very possible that
other people when they talk about
consciousness and are interested in it i
think they're
interested in some other aspect that i'm
not thinking about okay
i like this this was from this is a
quote from one of your papers
my belief is that the most foundational
research either assumes too much or is
too focused
on specific subfields of physics for
example i do not believe that one can
effectively study the foundations of
quantum mechanics and ignore probability
theory gravity
electromagnetism and other related
phenomenon the universe is a package
a package deal and to understand it
requires an understanding of that
package
as a whole certainly progress is made
in relatively small steps but if one is
to seriously think about solving this
puzzle
one has to keep in mind the whole
picture
while one is trying to place a
particular piece
now i had a sub question to that prior
to that you talked about machine
learning
so first of all i share that view all
right that's how i like that that's one
of the reasons i took that
quote out i believe you just
mentioned machine learning and what i'm
wondering is like what the heck does
machine learning have to do with
fundamental physics
unless you're stephen wolfram and you
think computation is at the core of it
all
what the heck does machine learning have
to do it all except with some problem
solving techniques
but i know well so what does machine
learning have to do with fundamental
physics so what did i
well i'm not sure what i said about
machine learning before that um
i think you talked about maybe it was on
your website and i'm just conflating
quite a bit of information you talked
about that one of your advantages is
that you came from machine learning and
you can apply that to
physics now i imagine what you were
referring to was
fundamental physics at least in these
papers i'm not sure
if you were no were you is there an
application of machine learning oh no i
don't think i was
when i said pat i don't think i was
referring to the foundational physics i
think i was referring to
some of the other work i do with
exoplanet characterization
and some of the astrophysics work i've
done
yes okay you worked with someone by the
way from u of t
my hometown my bailiwick u of t for
spectral inference
from a multiplexing fourier transform
spectrometer oh
yes yep
okay why don't you explain each of those
terms spectral
inference from a multiplexing fourier
transform spectrometer so let's
spectral inference what is that
referring to what is that so the idea is
that we
are inferring the spectrum from
data recorded from the interferometer
basically the
the device works by taking in we were
looking at stars
and so we were taking taking light in um
beam splitter split it up and then you
have a delay line that you can vary the
length
and then you recombine them and
you get an interference pattern and so
so you either have constructive
interference or deconstructive
interference and depending on the
and it depends on how much you have it
depends on how much
of each frequency or wavelength you have
in the original light beam
so as you vary this delay length um
the side length of this interferometer
you'll you'll
get interference fringes so these um
so by doing that you can then look at
that interference pattern
and then infer what some spectrum
had to be present that to give you that
interference pattern
i see i see now interferometers is that
what ligo uses to detect gravitational
waves
yeah okay okay now multiplexing fourier
transform so fourier transform should be
familiar
but what's a multiplexing for you let me
try to remember what
the what that referred to
you might have used that adjective just
to describe that we can
look at multiple wavelengths at once
can you not do that with a traditional
usually usually with an interferometer
you're using like with ligo
you'll take a laser beam at a given
wavelength and then you
are look waiting for an interference
pattern and as a gravitational wave
comes by that
actually stretches your your delay lines
right and that's what you detect so in
this case you're not
yeah you're just taking light in so it's
multiple frequencies
spectrometer now what is that so
spectrometer is used to measure the
spectrum
of the light so you can determine what
wavelengths are present in that beam of
light
i'm mispronouncing these words but
hopefully you can understand what i'm
trying to say so what is this
what's the relationship between the
spectrometer and the inferometer
ah well there usually is no relationship
in this device we use
the interferometer to figure out what
the spectrum is so the whole
device is then called a spectrometer
so we're using an interferometer to
determine what wavelengths are present
nice and nice so the re the
end result is that we obtain a spectrum
of the incoming light
earlier in your career you used to work
on
auditory neural auditory yeah i did work
in neuroscience that's right
right okay so you said in particular i
was interested in the transition that
happens when one listens to clicks and
then increases it to let's say 40 hertz
so that's 40 times a second and then
perceptually it goes from
to just a tone
and then you had expected there to be
doubling effects due to
neural refractory periods now what i'm
wondering is
why would you expect okay so what do you
expect to double the frequency
over the period of the period i expected
there to be period doubling so i was
looking for
nonlinear effects in the auditory system
and i
expected that you'd have something like
period doubling bifurcations going on
like you see in nonlinear dynamics so
basically the idea is that the
neurons have a particular firing rate
and
they have a refractory period during you
know after they fire
they have a refractory period over which
they can't fire again
because they've got a build up the
chemical levels again right
um and so now if you so now if you
stimulate a neuron it'll fire
but if you stimulate it too fast then
you're going to start missing beets
because it'll fire and then you'll have
it be in refractory mode when you
trigger it again so it won't fire on
that one but then the second one it'll
fire again
but the next one it won't because it's
still refractory so you get a period
doubling and that's what i expected to
see in the auditory system
and i thought that that might be
responsible for
the perception of tones instead of
individual clicks and what are the
results
that wasn't what was responsible was
negative no i did not see that happen at
all
so in that it was interesting
well as a phd student it's disappointing
because it's a negative result
right so so my thesis had to do with a
negative result
and um and i did other things like map
out locations of active areas in the
brain using from
using mri so um
along with the along with the
encephalography which is what i was
recording
the um now it was interesting because it
was a few years later
i was reading a paper about
schizophrenics
and it turned out the authors discovered
that phenomena
in schizophrenics now they didn't
know about nonlinear dynamics so they
didn't call it the same thing but from
the period
the period doubling so looking at their
data it was clear that it was a period
doubling effect
so they found it in schizophrenics but i
didn't find it in normal people
so that was kind of interesting can that
be used to potentially diagnose
schizophrenia or oh i don't know
preconditions
yeah that's an interesting question i
didn't really pursue it so i didn't i
didn't i don't know
or i'm sure you heard about orchestrated
objective reduction from
penrose with regard to consciousness
no okay okay well anyway he has an
interesting theory as to why the wave
function collapses and it's because
right when it reaches a supers like the
question is
how does gravity come in because are you
in both space-time
in a superposition he would say yes
space time is
until it reaches a critical time
interval
or critical separation at which point it
then
chooses when it collapses and that's a
moment of proto-consciousness
it's actually a fascinatingly creative
theory i'm so surprised that someone
penrose a mainstr somewhat mainstream
physicist
would come up with this because it's so
bizarre anyway
when you were referring to the
perception of tones i was wondering hmm
do you have a theory as to why we
perceive it all of a sudden
to be uniform and continuous and i was
wondering if that was related to
orchestrated
objective reduction but anyway did you
manage to find out
why the tone became a tone and not a
series of clicks
no not really so i don't and i and i
haven't done that work since that time
so i don't know much about that now
if anything's been discovered since
okay all right all right why don't you
tell the audience a little bit about
your
position at nasa ames research center
at nasa yes so i was a
i was a research scientist at nasa ames
in the intelligent systems division
and so there what i did is i worked on
mostly on astrophysics problems
and designed machine learning algorithms
to analyze data
so we worked on for instance one of the
main projects i worked on was to
[Music]
work to create three-dimensional models
of planetary nebulae so planetary
nebulae are clouds of gas that surround
old stars these are stars that have
collapsed and become a white dwarf so
they
kind of puff off their outer atmospheres
and form a nebula and we had
obtained with with our sen hajian so the
same person at
um u of t that you mentioned earlier
with the fourier transform spectrometer
so this was our sentence project
originally and he had um
he had collected data with the hubble
space telescope
of of planetary nebula and he had
some imagery that were about five years
apart so you could actually see the
change in size
uh the change in angular size of the
object
we also had um doppler shift information
by looking at the
the um the the frequencies of light
coming off the nebula
part of the nebula is coming towards you
parts going away so you get a splitting
in the doppler lines
so we knew what the radial velocity was
and we knew the tangential angular size
change
and so we wanted to create a 3d model so
that we could relate the two
and figure out what the velocity is in
the tangential direction
uh because once you know the angular
size change and the velocity in that
direction then you can get the distance
to the nebula
and there aren't very many good
distance markers in the within you know
the galactic range so
so you know if things are within you
know a thousand parsecs or so you can
get
some idea of how far away it is and of
course if you
look at other galaxies and you see the
redshift from hubble expansion that you
can get distances there but distances
within the galaxy are very
poorly constrained so we were trying to
obtain 3d models of planetary nebulae
for distance markers
why why is it that the distances within
the galaxies are
troublesome you can't figure them out or
not you but one cannot
yeah well it's difficult they're two
your two we're talking about distances
where you're too far away to use
parallax
so you can't use parallax anymore from
the earth you know the earth is orbiting
the sun so you're
you get a parallax shift uh you're too
far away for that
and um you
don't accurately know you know to
get just there's a few ways to get
distances right so
cepheid variables are one you have
variable stars and you know
how they're varying in intensity and so
because you know the varying intensity
you can then figure out how far away
they are by looking at how much light
you receive
um so that so that's one way to get
distances but
other stars you can't exactly know what
their luminosity is
so you know you have some idea but you
have a lot of uncertainty there
and so you can't get a good you know
a reliable distance for for most objects
i see i see you see
you know a question that i asked avi
loeb that i don't think he gave me
a sufficient answer and you could help
me out it's that when i'm
when studying general relativity just
speaking about manifolds in general
and then the velocity at two different
points on a manifold
you can't actually compare velocity at
two different points
you can compare them when they're
together it's ill-defined to compare two
different points on a matter yeah you
have to you have to parallel transport
one vector to another and then compare
right
right okay so which implies a connection
now that's given by
einstein's equations but but what i'm
wondering is
when we're saying that a galaxy is
moving at a certain distance away from
us so we're utilizing that connection
to parallel transport it to be able to
say that it's moving at a certain speed
because otherwise the notion of velocity
i don't see how it's well defined if
they're
if they're sufficiently far away right
well understand what i'm saying that's
my
question explaining exactly no that's
fine um the
oh well that's interesting that's
something i hadn't quite conceived
of and i thought i really thought about
so
i mean we're talking i think we're
in that sense we're kind of ignoring the
well what avi lope said earlier in the
conversation was that
as far as we can tell the universe we
live in is somewhat flat so i thought
okay maybe that's
one way to get around that but let's
imagine that it's a sufficiently curvy
strange
manifold that we don't actually have an
idea as to what it is
how can one compare speeds
so is it just because it's flat or is it
for some other reason like we're making
assumptions about what exists and
so let's say you just assume that
there's a uniform density of particles
almost like dust
and in some cosmological models and then
you can extrapolate and get the big
whatever so you have some
model of how the galaxy is distributed
in mass
and then you use that then you're like
okay i can get the connection from that
so that i can
understand how these two points relate
to one another that's how i could
make sense of it but without that
calculate like what's going on in the
calculation that you can compare two
different velocities
as simple is it as simple as like a
we're just looking at it
like i would a baseball and compare i
guess i guess the
i guess there's an implicit assumption
that the
space time is basically flat between the
two of you
and that you then get a doppler you know
then the doppler shift is
solely due to the velocity of the object
if not due to
any space-time curvature
and i think that's the general i think
that's the basic assumption because you
know
you could be wrong i mean so imagine
that imagine that
our solar i mean we don't believe this
is the case but imagine that our solar
system is sitting in the middle of a
dark matter cloud right
and then now now you have now you have a
gravitational
um you have a gravitational redshift you
know coming into play
that you don't know about so now you're
you know you would get the wrong answers
for the velocity because you don't have
the
space-time coverage or down correctly
so so i think the implicit assumption is
that it's flat
and there's no dark matter right right
the more that is assumed in a theory the
more likely it is to be wrong that's a
quote from one of your papers
then so this is an argument about
parsimony then
to me what i'm wondering is the reason
why i dislike arguments about parsimony
is because
it would lead you to idealism that is
mind is all that exists
okay why would it lead you to that
because mind
exists in the sense that in a sense of
descartes so you believe that you're
conscious okay so then
what you see in front of you is like
contents within your mind
and then to posit that there's an
external world
is a second ontological step which means
it's actually
easier to just assume that this is all
occurring in mind
and then you're like well if it's in
mind then why
are there regularities well you could
say there's regularities in mind this is
something that bernardo castro argues he
says that actually
idealism is the
the best philosophical thought if one is
to take parsimony seriously
i'm curious why don't you take the step
of just saying idealism is correct
unless you do maybe you do i don't know
what your philosophical framework is
why don't you take that step if you're
making an argument about parsimony
that less assumptions are better
right so so maybe
so maybe to answer that it better for me
to
talk about what we mean
or why why one would invoke parsimony
in that particular argument
so in my theoretical
my more recent theoretical work
i have
i've taken the a very a very different
perspective
so you know typically we have a um
you know we have these ideas of physical
law there's a physical law
and um and i think you were um talking
to eric weinstein about this you know
what makes the electron fall what makes
it obey the physical law right
and um
and so we have this idea that there are
these there exists these laws that we
discover
right and um you know so
where do the laws come from you know you
worry about that and we worry about
whether different
you know if there's a multiverse
different universes could they have
different laws
you know you have that question come up
um which is a natural question when you
have no idea where the laws come from
right
so so the
so you either believe that you know
mother nature has
you know dictated a set of laws and then
somehow make sure that the electron
follows them right
and so you have that going on or
um or is it something else
and so the
i guess i've i've come to think of it
more in terms
of you know the law when we talk about
laws we're usually talking about
our mathematical form formulation of
physics right because this is what we
use to make
quantitative predictions and when i when
we say quantitative what do we mean well
we're assigning numbers to things
right so so how does one assign numbers
to things
and that's so that's a question and that
one could ask
and i and i had worried about this in
graduate school i got
it was frustrating i i had asked
a very simple question and i was trying
to understand
you know i said why is it when i take
two pens and i combine them
with another pin i always get third
three pens why why does that happen and
i
and i wasn't of course asking why is it
three and not four i know that it's
three
i'm very familiar with this um
but what i was wondering is is this a
is this an experimental result where you
had to do an experiment to find out that
it was three
and or is it a theoretical result where
this is how you define three
or is it a definition do we define three
this way
um where what do we mean when we you
know when we think about that
and so i had had asked that question in
graduate school
and that that really didn't go well
because they
um i ended up having several professors
make
make some fun of me basically oh and
oh i think we're having internet
connections here
huh it might be on my side because
you're completely fine as far as
okay yeah so so the um
it was at the moment that i read that in
your
paper once that i realized man this guy
is far more interesting than i
initially thought i mean i already
thought you were interesting and i was
excited to thank you just about uap and
then i saw that and then i was like okay
so this person is actually thinking
about physics
not in the same way not to say that you
think about it
not to compliment myself by saying i
think about it anyway like you
but i'm saying there's similarities
you you definitely are thinking
foundationally
and i'm so super excited okay great
so essentially the effectiveness of
mathematics yeah so
so why does why does math work why does
that why does that work and i
and yeah so i had um several professors
would make fun if i asked a question in
class oh here
kevin who doesn't know why we add things
when we combine them as a question
and that was that was a little
frustrating and some of the graduate
students made fun as well
that's fine um what it did
for me though is it solidified in my
mind that
they don't actually know the answer to
the question either
no no it was it was clear very obvious
to me
no one had the answer to that and so it
remained kind of a mystery in my mind
and um in some way
clearly became a driving force you know
at some level
uh was it wasn't one that i was aware of
initially
um meaning that it was at the back of
your mind
probably at the back of my mind and when
the time came
for it to be you know relevant it it
was right there and ready so mm-hmm
and it became relevant years later
because you were
it was years later yeah it was years
later and i was
um pretty much when i was working at
nasa
i was trying to
develop machines that autonomously
performed experiments
so i didn't want to do i wanted to do
calculations with questions
so the idea is that you can you have an
issue you want to resolve but you can't
ask that question directly but you can
ask questions that
have answers that imply um the answers
to that
question you do want to ask i don't
understand give me an example yeah so
you might want to
know you know is there you know you've
got a martian rover
it's looking at a rock and there's green
stuff on it and you want to say oh is
that stuff alive
right that's the question the issue when
you want to resolve is that alive
well you can't the rover can't just ask
are you alive
right that doesn't work that way so it
has to perform an experiment
so you know you could do raman
spectroscopy
and collect a spectrum you know a raman
spectrum from that and get some
idea of what molecules are present
and that's a question and gives you an
answer and the answer would be what
molecules are present
and then the question is does that then
you have to worry about whether
that result that that um
that assertion that you get from
from analyzing your data then how that
um is relevant to the issue what you
want to resolve
you know how how relevant is this to
whether it's alive or not
yeah so is it better to step on it and
see if it dies or is it better to take a
ramen's
spectrum and look at that what's a ramen
spectrum like ramen as in ramen noodles
or
uh r-a-m-a so it's it's basically
you um shine a laser beam at this and
the
light scatters off the um the light
scatters off the
the mole it doesn't destroy the specimen
right
okay cool it doesn't destroy the
specimen right so
so that was the original idea so i
wanted to do computations with questions
and i had had some experience in
deriving
uh probability theory and so
i was using that as kind of a framework
for getting started
and the
basically what you what when you work
with that what you realize is that
if i want to assign a number to a
question actually i'm assigning numbers
to pairs of questions and i
want to quantify how relevant question a
is to my the issue i want to resolve
so this idea of relevance so i want to
assign a number to
this relevance which is a function of
two questions
and um so how do you consistently assign
numbers
um to this quantity
and that's the question that's that's
what you need to ask at that point
and you find that if you you can combine
questions in different ways you can ask
you know is it um this or that right
so you can use or as a conjunction and
um you can join two questions with an or
and you know are you drinking pepsi or
mountain dew
it could be your question and when you
do that
you find that you know the or the
logical order there when combining two
questions
is commutative and and it's also
associative if you
included more questions and that puts
some serious constraints on the numbers
that you would assign
to that joint question based on as a
function of the
the questions that you're joining and
you can show that it has to be additive
um or
or in isomorphic it has to be isomorphic
to
additivity so you can choose it to be
additive and
keep it simple um and
that's basically how that work started
so
so um and you were graduate at this
point
you were a graduate in nasa or yeah i
was a i was a research scientist at nasa
at that point
because the work that i see you're doing
with saying that so-and-so is
commutative so-and-so is associated with
so it's distributed
and therefore has this implication to
physics that work i see it as being
recent
so you took that thinking from your
research days and then applied it or did
you apply back then
no i i didn't i didn't i didn't apply it
for oops my computer as an
error report this is fine i'll ask i'll
re-ask the question what i'm wondering
is
as you're a research scientist there i
don't know how old you were let's say 30
28 35 yeah it was 2 000 so it had been
about 35 yep
okay so you're 35 great oh i got one of
those numbers okay so you were 35.
you weren't thinking right then about
the foundations of physics you were just
trying to
solve this problem of how can we ask it
a question and get some feedback how can
we quantify questions that was basically
what i was doing yeah
then maybe 10 years later you realize oh
okay okay wait that's interesting
i can take that and let's see how far i
can run with it and apply to
the foundation yeah well around that
time that i was trying to quantify
questions
i had seen a talk by ariel katicha
who is a colleague of mine now here at
suny albany
um and he's he's one of the reasons i'm
here at suny albany
we became friends and and um
so he had given a talk on uh
foundations of quantum mechanics and he
used some of the similar arguments
you know of associativity and
distributivity to
um to
derive the the um the feynman path
integral formulation of quantum
mechanics
so he had done something very similar to
this with experimental setup so the idea
was that your
he was quantifying an experimental setup
and then if you combine
so you've got an experimental setup
where you've got a light going through a
single slit
and then you've got another experimental
setup with light going through a single
set and now you combine these two and
now you have two slits
um so how do you perform computations
with these and forgive my ignorance
it's been a little while but is
feynman's path into girl is that how is
that related to feynman's
he has a checkerboard as well i believe
feynman checkerboard
i thought that one was the continuous
limit of the other so they're not
related
oh oh one yeah well you could certainly
the path integral would be a continuous
version of the checkerboard yeah okay
because
actually i hadn't heard about the
checkerboard until when i was reading
about how you took causal sets and then
said
well you can recreate some of the
characteristics of feynman
checkerboard then checkerboard say right
there cause the checkerboard whatever
you got the idea
okay continue please sorry that i'm
interrupting i'm just making sure i'm
understanding it correctly right so i
had seen
so i'd seen it talk by ariel katicha
about experimental setups and how to
quantify experimental setups and so
that had stuck in my mind and
um so it wasn't until years later that
i was you know when um
i was working with philip goyal who was
he was at the perimeter institute at the
time
near where you are and um we were
talking about quantum mechanics and how
similar
um the feynman rules uh which are
basically when you are
you know combining two things in two cis
um experiments in parallel you basically
sum the complex numbers
and when you put them in series you
multiply complex numbers and those are
your
ample quantum amplitudes and
we were talking about how similar those
rules look look to
the sum and product rules of probability
theory
and and i mentioned in passing i said
well
you know you can drive the summon
product rules with you know these basic
algebraic symmetries so
probably you should be able to do that
with quantum mechanics as well
and we started working on it that
evening and
um made a good bit of progress
and um then um
got our friend john skilling involved
and
basically wrote their first paper our
first pass at that work there that was
based on that so that's basically how
that
those ideas came about
and so so more recently i'm working with
john skilling and i think that's the
paper you're looking at
yeah for the audience there are about
six papers of yours that i find to be
extremely interesting and i'm gonna
state them in any one and i'll list them
in the description so people can view
them so the ones that i find interesting
are the origins
of complex quantum amplitudes and
finding rules pretty much
quantum theory and probability theory
their relationship in origin and
symmetry
a potential foundation for emergent
space time
now that one i wasn't able to go through
in detail the understanding of the
electron
hmm now that one that one's absolutely
that one's more philosophical and that
one you're a soul author
okay the arithmetic of uncertainty that
unifies quantum formalism and
relativistic space
that one i made notes on which i'm gonna
ask all right great
and then the last one an essay
sorry there's two ones there's one
that's an introduction to influence
theory
see a couple of these are extremely
similar so the foundation
of emergent space time what do you call
influence theory is that that's the uh
yeah
influence theory basically came out of
yeah it came out of
the um emergent space-time work
okay and is that where you have a chain
and then one influences one
other that you're calling influence
theory yeah okay because when i first
read that i thought
it's like influence theory hadn't heard
about that is that some way of speaking
about causation
is that some is that something new that
i shouldn't so
it's something you've coined is that
correct yeah like we created that yeah
yeah so the idea is that the you know
what
really matters is what you're really
quantifying in quantum mechanics is
you're
quantifying interactions you're
interested in what happens when
something interacts with something else
so
we work to strip that down to the bare
essentials
and um and ended up with these
uh partially ordered sets of of
interaction events
yeah it's definitely the bare essentials
yeah and then we work to quantify it
and you know how can you quantify it
while there's basic symmetries
that are that are imposed by the by the
basic structure that you've assumed and
those symmetries tell you how to
quantify it and then
the laws emerge as constraint equations
that enforce those symmetries i was
talking to someone now i'm not sure how
far
in the ama my ema you got but i was
someone was saying well there are
different kinds of podcasts and there's
like the joe rogan podcast and so
then i said mine is more of office hours
i feel like i have a professor
and i want to make sure that i
understand what the professor's saying
it's office hours it's not
don't think of it like it's an interview
don't think of it like it's a
documentary or joe rogan
i'm not here to just have a beer and
have a conversation with all we can do
that
i'm like i have questions anyone know
yeah it does feel like office hours
that's what i
yeah that's one thing i enjoy about
watching you know watching your podcasts
great great great okay it's great fun
and it's it's informative for that
reason you go into some depth and
makes it really interesting yeah thank
you thank you so much
okay so so have some notes here and i
want to make sure that i'm understanding
the paper of arithmetic of uncertainty
so it's also okay showing that the
mathematical structures of quantum
theory and relativity formed from pure
so he said well that's more of a
question for later
start so this is what i understand what
you've done and so please correct me
you start from assuming or suggesting
that commutativity distribution
associativity are so fundamental that
they're taken as axioms
then you define a scalar you're like
okay then we're like now that we've got
a scalar let's make a two vector
and then let's put some extra structure
on that two vector for multiplication
almost like an algebra
that we don't put the structure on you
the structure is imposed by the symmetry
then you get something that resembles
the poly matrices then you say well let
determine it equal one
and then you get something that
resembles poly matrices even more this
time you give them
generator status and you call them
matrices a b and c
then you say there's an unknown phase
associated with each
unit determinant two vector and
hey i i had a question there let's
forget about that
then you have an unknown phase and then
you say well this unknown phase let's
give it uniform probability
then you get that phase and you say
yes then you say that this phase has to
be continuous necessarily
necessarily and thus you've found a way
to derive continuity instead of assuming
continuity okay then you get
bourne's rule by saying the ignorance of
the phase means you can only measure
averages and here's one way here's the
way you measure averages
now please correct me if what i'm saying
is foolish or it's incorrect yeah no
you've got you've got
much much of the basic idea the the um
so so it starts with
referring back to our earlier work with
quantifying things with a scalar so if
you're going to use one number to
quantify
something then um if
the so yeah so i quantify one object
with a number and i quantify this object
with another and now if i combine them
in some way
and this combination rule is commutative
and associative
then the number that i assigned to the
combination
i want that to be some function of the
two numbers that i've assigned to the
original objects um
if they if i don't then they're not
related to each other yeah yeah yeah
there's no point i think they have that
i'm doing this i believe those are the
gamma
numbers right so now yeah so here we'll
give this a number and we give this a
number and then combine them and we'll
give this
a different number now what number
you know i might have some choice as to
what numbers i assigned to these two but
then
what number should i assign to these two
that's gonna should be of some function
of the number i assigned to this one
and a function of the number i assigned
to this one but it shouldn't matter
you know whether i joined them this way
or join them that way right communicator
communicative
they're associative so if i'm joining
three i can combine them together like
this or i can combine it like that
so that constrains severely constrains
the number that you assign to the three
objects or the j the joint object
and it turns out you can prove that that
has to be isomorphic to addition
so it's basically addition or
something that is a an invertible
transform of addition
so multiplication is an invertible
transform of addition as well
yeah so that's so that's basically why i
could take
i can take this stuff and give it a
number two
and take this one and give it a number
one and when i put them together
what number do i sign this group well
it's one plus two three
and that's actually why you sum things
when you combine them that answers my
original question in graduate school but
it has to do with
associativity and cognitivity of the
joining operation
what struck me was how elementary it was
and i wonder not to demean it but
how the heck is it that other people
haven't come up with this it's so
elementary it's so simple it's the
opposite of demeaning sorry i'm
complimenting no i'm wondering i agree
i actually feel asinine that
i didn't come up with this it almost
looks so
obvious that it doesn't require saying
right
the the there was a um
we've revised that paper now or we're
working on revising this paper
we work with a pair of numbers um
because we have a quantity and an
uncertainty
we acknowledge that you're always going
to be uncertain at a fundamental level
you're going to have some uncertainty
so the question is how do you account
for this uncertainty um
you could you know your first response
would be to say oh it's quantity plus or
minus
some sigma right that would be your
first go to
but but you we basically
account for the fact that there might be
a more
subtle or more intimate relationship
there
and so we say let's just start with two
numbers and then see
how those numbers have to evolve you
know as we
do these perform these um acts of
combination
so was it that at first you tried
naively the plus or minus
and then it didn't lead anywhere
fruitful so then you're like how about i
be more general and say i don't know how
to combine these two
no i guess i was talking about um
quantity plus uncertainty yes yes
oh and then i was wondering why did you
make that generalization like what
spurred you to do so
right so the idea was to treat them as
two
two numbers and figure out how
do the symmetries the algebraic
symmetries dictate
we deal with these numbers so with
addition it's it's quite simple when you
um
are so when you have just combination
with associativity and commutativity
then it's just a transform
an invertible transform of component
wise addition so
so you can just use addition for that so
um that's pretty straightforward
multiplication is more interesting so so
now if you
um combine objects in series
and now you have um
associativity commutativity
associativity and distributivity
and that imposes some extra constraints
so with a scalar you
then get also get addition but it can't
be addition because you've already used
that for
the for the um parallel combination
so it has to be a transform of addition
you can prove that
multiplication works and that's what
gives you the sum and product rules and
probability theory
but when you have two numbers you um
you don't have simple multiplication
anymore you're basically dealing with
two by two matrices
and it turns out that there are three
different ways to do it
so so we get so we get matrix a we get
matrix b
non-degenerate yeah that's right three
that are non-degenerate
so matrix a b and c and so
we then um back up and say look
we are originally we're dealing with
you know the original motivation was to
quantify
objects while taking into account
uncertainties
so what happens if we now actually treat
these as uncertainties using
probability theory and if you do that
you find that
only matrix a works in that case and it
gives you
complex addition and complex
multiplication
so you then are you then learn
that what you what you're constrained to
do in that situation is
to use complex numbers and
if you then want to assign a scalar
to that same system then you can derive
the born rule that way
and so that that gives you the complex
formalism of quantum mechanics one of my
questions
was basically what instigated this was
why is it it's so fun it's so elementary
that i'm wondering how the heck did
people not see this before
that's a good question i don't know i
think that
part of it is perspective i don't hear
your name on
a list of toes theories of everything
with
string and loop and so on i'm not saying
that you claim to have a theory of
everything but you definitely derive
are more fundamental which to me is puts
you in the class of a theory of
everything
why haven't i heard it yeah well i i
don't know
i don't know why either that's a good
question it seems to take several years
for some of this work to filter into the
community
um there's a there's a delay people are
working on their own ideas right and
it's hard to
take the time to look at somebody else's
ideas and to do that
well you have to it's a deep dive right
so
so it takes time and effort um
why hasn't it been done before i think
it's a matter of perspective
if you're thinking of the laws of
physics as
laws you know that are dictated by
mother nature
then you go about handling them
differently
so how should they be conceptualized
that are not law
i mean here in this case we're thinking
about it in terms of quantifying things
you know if i want to assign numbers to
things how do i how can i do it and so
so it's a rather unique perspective that
and it it bore fruit it was it was
useful
was one term in your paper that i kept
getting confused by it was
quantification
it's not a term that i've heard well
it suggests something but i wasn't sure
like what's the definition of
quantification and how are you using it
well i mean i use that just to
describe the act of quantifying
something so i assign numbers
how do you go about assigning numbers to
things
and um and then you know and
and of course then the real question is
what happens to
how do you assign a number to
combinations of things and that's what
we're really after
okay well let's just finish up so what's
your opinion on
i'll just read through the questions so
that you get an idea and then you can
answer them sure okay back to the
beginning so opinion on string theory
opinion on loop
opinion on geometric unity opinion on
stephen wolframs
i'll answer it don't answer any of these
yeah i'm going to okay i just want you
to get the lay of the land
picture all right okay where did these
la
okay why these laws and not another
and then two audience questions one was
from stephen paul king he says ask him
about space his space-time ideas you've
already talked about that
and robot scientist concept i have no
clue what that is
maybe you do and then steve scully wants
to know about
nothingness and infinity being the same
let's get to this opinion on string
theory we can go through this quick
what's your opinion on string theory
string theory it's tough
it's it's i think it's too high level
the
um
i'm work i guess i'm working at a level
where i'm driving
mean we just talked about how i do how
we're deriving
the fact that you need to use complex
numbers in quantum mechanics right and
the fact that
you know how do you manipulate these
complex numbers this the sum and product
rules
um that's what i'm working to derive in
string theory
there's a different approach the idea is
instead of point particles we're going
to have
loops of string and then we're going to
just apply quantum mechanics to it
so it's too high level i mean you're
applying quantum mechanics well
where does quantum mechanics come from
why do you use quantum mechanics and
that's something else
right and that's that's a question i
would ask
i have a question about that why is it
that you derive quantum mechanics and
not
qft well we well we we haven't we
haven't applied it to
so we haven't applied it to space time
yet so it's
you know we're just you're working at
the basics what happened how do you
quantify a quantum system well you're
going to need these complex numbers
that's what we we've derived that how do
you
calculate the probabilities from those
complex numbers well you derive the
bourne rule
um so it's it's building up from the
bottom so what are your thoughts on loop
similar and geometric unity um
i i think it's a similar you know my my
opinion similar at the
the levels you know you're you're
constructing your fundamental theory too
high up
how about wolframs i see wolfram's is
being amenable to yours or yours
amenable now his is very yeah no his is
a very low level theory and that
that i think i'm more you know agreeable
toward
um i don't tend to see the universe as a
computer so
i differ in that aspect does your theory
have anything to say about black holes
or the information paradox or the
beginning of the universe or is it too
early right now it's too early yeah okay
now just two audience questions and
that's it man so stephen paul king wants
to know
ask him about space-time ideas or his
space-time ideas we've done that
and his robot scientist concept he is
amazing in my opinion
thank you very much steve wow um
oh the space time business first um i
should i should
be a little clear about the work that
we've done with influence theory
one of we've run into some difficulty
in that we can describe
one dimension one plus one dimensional
space time very nicely
three plus one is very weird and very
difficult so it's not clear that we can
handle
the theory seems to be too linear um
so three plus one space times difficult
however
that being said i can use their work in
influence theory to derive
the dimensionality that
you know space is in this theory space
is a description
right space isn't a physical thing it's
a description of events
so i can derive how many numbers you
should need
to describe events generally and i
actually have such a definition
and the result is three plus one three
dimensions of space one plus time
only thing that works and based on
symmetries
in that theory but but strangely
the theory cannot actually i haven't
been able to
use the theory to describe three plus
one dimensional space time
i can't use it to just use use four
numbers to describe events
and so we're kind of stuck there which
is why i
kind of i for a year basically took off
uh from working on that work and then
teamed up with john skilling to work the
on the paper that you're reading now
with you know arithmetic of uncertainty
as for the robot scientist concept is
that the same as the mars rover
yeah that's similar to the quantifying
relevance so the idea oh i used to joke
you know when i when i would give a talk
on this i would give a joke
you know joke around how you know i'm
trying to um make experimentalists
obsolete by
automating an experimental design
um of course that's not going to happen
but um but that that's the basic idea is
to
perform if you can perform computations
with questions
which turns out to be very closely
related to information theory it's it's
information theory plus a little bit
more which is nice
and you can then use that to
for machines to figure out what
experiments to do
to accomplish certain you know
resolve certain issues to basically
accomplish certain goals
so if you want to learn something about
that rock
you know you can actually perform
computations to figure out
which experiments to perform and based
on the data that you get you can figure
out which experiment to perform next and
so on until
you reach the requisite precision that's
the basic idea with that
behind that work great last question is
from steve scully who has a youtube
channel that i'll link in the
description he steve scully has a theory
of everything
and he wants to know
just for the audience steve scully has
an idea that nothing is the same as
infinity
i don't know if you've heard about this
maybe you get emails from people
suggesting theories of everything to you
and saying you should read this or you
should read my paper and so on
well have you come across this idea that
zero is the same as infinity or infinity
is the same as zero
asked exactly how i don't know because i
don't understand steve scully's
theory yeah i haven't gone through it
but
what do you make of that that's
interesting and no i don't i don't get
emails about that i usually get emails
with pictures of
lights and people are asking me what
they are
and i usually respond by saying there
they appear to be lights i what they're
attached to i can't possibly tell you
because
they're lights um so that's what i
usually get
from in my emails the let's see
i thought you were going somewhere else
is zero pictures
is zero equal to infinity well that's
difficult
infinity isn't really a number right
infinity is a concept
so so it's hard to
imagine any kind of equivalence between
a a number and a concept and now
no zero a number that's a little messy
too zero is also a concept right
but they're different concepts so i
don't i don't see how they're the same
but i'm not familiar with his work
so okay so his actual question that was
mine is is it possible that the universe
is infinite
that is that there's no end to how large
or how small
objects in the universe can be relative
to one another
and that if the overall system is to be
comprehensible
it is only by us recognizing how all
these apparently separate and distinct
systems
actually share some underlying mechanism
yeah i'm not sure how to begin um
so i i it sounds like his ideas that
things can be arbitrarily small and
arbitrarily large
and there's no limit to this well
yeah i don't know what to make of that
um
it's hard because i'm not sure how you
could tell
how would you ever know that they can be
arbitrarily small
so
usually my thinking is that if
if it if the arbitrarily
if the arbitrary smallness of things
isn't detectable then it doesn't matter
and you wouldn't
you don't no you won't you won't know
about it and you don't need to know
about it
um so
so i'm not sure that it you know i i if
i'm not sure you would notice and i'm
not sure it would matter if that were
the case
so that's difficult
professor it was great thank you so much
for speaking with me
for three or four hours i don't know how
long that was yeah
about i guess we're in three plus texts
where can the audience find out more
about you
and do you have anything to promote oh i
i have
um let's see knuth lab.org is my
is my um website so you can check that
out
um anything i want to promote actually i
i do have something i want to promote i
don't have a good
i'll send you the link to it um i'm
working on designing a card game
so this is totally out of left field i
it basically came from the fact i read
an article
oh about two and a half years ago now
where
um why i don't know what the
percentage was but some tiny percent or
something like 80 percent of americans
couldn't name a living scientist
and i was really struck by that i
thought that's crazy
um and and my son came home from
school that day he was in third grade at
the time
and he had made some good trades with
his pokemon cards and he was telling me
all about this pokemon card and this
character and he traded for this one and
this is better because he has this
ability in this ability
and i thought 80 percent of americans
can't name a living scientist yet my
third grade son
knows all about these fictional japanese
characters and their superpowers and i
thought
what's what's wrong with this picture
and so i've
designed a card game with scientists and
um and i'm looking for scientists to
actually sign up
for the card game so um so i'm still
trying to find scientists i especially
want
especially what women and minorities
because i really want to have the game
very well balanced
and so that everyone's well represented
and um
and that's the goal is to get that game
going so if
any of you viewers are happen to be
scientists or
or basically um stem professionals
though they work too um please consider
you know you can email me or um or you
can go to the link and you can um
join by creating a card for yourself
right what about people who are
illustrators if they want to volunteer
their time to make
the pictures for the cards oh that's a
nice idea
yeah if somebody is interested i was
i had planned on using mostly stock
images but i
you know if somebody is interested in
illustrating and wants to volunteer for
that that might be nice too
yeah it would look more pleasant if
there was a uniform graphic design
yeah as for yep that's that's
interesting i know all the pokemon as
well so
i joined your signs right charizard
i don't know if you've heard of
charizard that's the most valuable
pokemon card to me charizard wow
all right
you